Traduttore: Sebastiano Inama
Revisore: Federico Sangati
Buongiorno a tutti.
Noi siamo due architetti, designer.
Nella professione facciamo cose
molto normali: disegniamo lampade, mobili,
interni, mostre e qualche architettura,
però durante tutta
la nostra vita professionale
ci dedichiamo anche ad alcune riflessioni
che poi mettiamo anche sulla carta,
e cerchiamo di rappresentare,
magari in occasione di qualche mostra.
Per cui oggi racconteremo
questa "casa liberata"
e cercheremo di far capire
che cosa vuol dire
attraverso questi cinque progetti
che hanno diverse scale.
Sono progetti sperimentali,
non saranno applicati immediatamente,
quindi a volte parliamo di fisica teorica
e di fisica applicata.
Questi studiano l'abitare come fenomeno.
Il tema della casa, tra l'altro,
è diventato di grande attualità
nell'ultimo decennio
con la crisi finanziaria,
fenomeni nuovi o molto urgenti
come l'immigrazione, le nuove povertà,
la crisi stessa del ceto medio
che è troppo ricca per chiedere
una casa popolare, ma troppo povera
per acquistarne una dal libero mercato.
Quindi questa domanda di abitazione,
del duemila, dell'ultimo decennio,
è molto frammentata,
segmentata e mutevole,
quindi son condizioni nuove che richiedono
delle risposte non solo quantitative,
ma anche qualitative,
quindi molto differenti da quell'idea
di housing sociale
degli anni Sessanta e Settanta
e che era basata sullo standard,
quindi sull'idea di una casa per tutti.
Adesso il tema è una casa per ciascuno,
dove la reversibilità, la flessibilità,
la mobilità, la mutevolezza dell'assetto
della casa stessa è il tema centrale,
come è nei nostri progetti di ricerca.
In questo progetto, sviluppato qualche
anno fa l'abbiamo chiamato Agronica
assieme all'architetto Andrea Branzi,
abbiamo riassunto un po' questi concetti,
che stava dicendo Giovanni:
mobilità, reversibilità.
È un modello di metropoli,
un modello di una città,
un pensiero su una città, che noi
chiamiamo debole, molto diffusa,
una specie di grande campagna:
potrebbe essere la Pianura Padana,
o una pianura dell'Olanda.
E qui vediamo questo territorio,
cablato con questi pilastri,
dove alcuni elementi architettonici
scorrono e si muovono,
l'opposto della città che abbiamo oggi,
in cemento, in pietra,
stabile e durevole negli anni.
Un po' segue appunto il modello
dell'agricoltura, o delle colture,
dove io semino una volta una coltura,
poi dopo qualche anno la cambio.
Seguiva un po' questo tipo di modello,
secondo noi estremamente innovativo.
Poi c'è il desiderio di vivere
nella natura,
che è uno dei grandi sogni
della modernità.
D'altra parte,
voleva anche superare lo "zoning",
forse molti di voi non sanno cos'è,
ma anche questo è uno dei grandi concetti
che si è sviluppato nel secolo scorso,
cioè la divisione della città
per aree omogenee.
La città moderna nasce un po' così:
c'è la città dello shopping,
quella del tempo libero,
quella dove si produce,
e quella dove si vive, che è poi l'opposto
della città ibrida e preindustriale
prima della rivoluzione industriale.
Agronica vuole tornare a questo modello,
cioè a re-ibridare le nostre attività:
il negozio che ritorna sotto casa,
l'artigiano nella piazzetta a fianco
e non a questa città,
divisa invece per attività omogenee.
La fine dello 'zoning': di questo teorema,
paradigma moderno, qui è visibile
a livello di scala territoriale,
quindi con questa compenetrazione
tra città e campagna, tra spazi dedicati
alla residenza e alla produzione,
ma è anche una condizione
che noi abbiamo cercato di ricreare
all'interno della casa stessa,
e vedrete dalle prossime immagini
che non ci sono più dei muri, delle stanze
che definiscono un assetto definitivo
e definito dell'abitazione,
ma ci sono degli spazi compattati,
degli armadi, dove vengono compattate
funzioni, tecnologie e comportamenti.
In questo video vediamo
come tutti questi oggetti vanno a finire
in queste scatole, un po' quello
che è successo con questo tipo di oggetti;
qui dentro abbiamo una telecamera,
una fotocamera, un telefono, una mail.
Ci sono un sacco di cose qui dentro, ed è
una delle strategie, questa compattazione
che va avanti da anni ed è usata
in tantissimi prodotti.
Qui abbiamo provato ad applicarla
alla casa.
Questi che vedete sono come degli armadi,
sono simili nel
funzionamento ai mobili delle farmacie.
Ho una pianta, che ora vediamo,
immaginiamo un appartamento,
anche abbastanza piccolo, 8x8,
dove nelle pareti ci sono questi armadi
che posso noleggiare o comprare secondo
la composizione del nucleo familiare,
magari solo un singolo, solo una coppia,
ed estraggo praticamente le mie stanze,
i mobili, perché poi è un po' difficile
capire cosa sono questi oggetti,
sono a metà tra un mobile e uno spazio,
sono dei mobili abitabili,
e come si vede dalla pianta,
o dalle foto successive,
di volta in volta estrarrò lo spazio
di cui ho necessità, e la casa
diventa tutta quanta una stanza da letto,
tutta quanta una stanza studio,
oppure mette in relazione delle stanze,
dei momenti della vita che normalmente
non hanno una connessione, non hanno
una planimetria tradizionale di abitazione.
Questa teoria del 'compattare'
fa parte comunque della tradizione,
è uno dei paradigmi moderni,
l'existence spinning,
che non è nient'altro che la ricerca
di spazi minimi, di luoghi minimi,
per poi creare
abitazioni economiche.
Nel nostro caso, il compattare non serve
per un'economia di tipo monetario
ma per creare uno spazio disponibile,
un vuoto potenziale e sempre libero,
non progettato, e quindi
che serve per le attitudini,
per quello che seguirà nel futuro,
per la potenzialità del divenire,
piuttosto che definire la casa
su delle necessità definitive.
C'è anche qui una una specie di rottura,
di questa idea dello zoning,
che divideva la città
appunto in zone omogenee.
La casa anche: abbiamo la stanza da letto,
abbiamo il bagno, il living, eccetera.
Questa diventa anche una metafora
di quello che accade sul nostro monitor,
le nostre attività diventano dei file,
che posso aprire e far interagire
in maniera sempre diversa.
In sostanza una casa
molto più autobiografica,
che può cambiare nel tempo a seconda
delle necessità che si verranno a creare.
Questo è un po' lo stesso discorso,
solo che sale di scala,
ad una scala quasi architetturale,
una specie di condominio,
lo vediamo in questo piccolo video,
molto elementare,
di solito nell'architettura c'è l'hardware
cioè travi, pilastri, solette, eccetera,
e poi ci sono una serie di attività
che vengono messe successivamente,
ciò che noi chiamiamo 'software'.
In queste griglie noi mettiamo
i nostri oggetti, che ci aiutano
a fare le nostre attività.
È anche una metafora ripresa
dal mondo dell'elettronica:
l'idea di un computer
che riempi di software,
di applicazioni,
a seconda dell'uso che ne vuoi fare.
Non c'è una tecnologia
che dà un uso definitivo e definito,
ma sono le applicazioni, i software,
che creeranno
l'utilizzo reale della macchina.
Quest sistema ha uno scaffolding,
una grande struttura che viene riempita
da spazi in maniera verticale,
a seconda delle necessità.
Potrò compormi una casa
con un giardino personale,
se ho l'hobby del giardinaggio,
con quattro stanze da letto
se mi piace dormire,
con tre stanze per cucinare
se mi piace cucinare.
Quindi una casa dove non c'è uno zoning,
un'identità definitiva, ma la possibilità
di renderla molto più vicina
alle nostre esigenze
e ai nostri desideri.
Compongo la casa,
così come faccio shopping,
comprando o noleggiando
spazi e servizi.
Esatto, ed è proprio
la logica del prodotto:
nella stessa maniera in cui
il prodotto mi dà questa enorme libertà
di cambiarlo e sostituirlo,
di noleggiarlo,
a seconda delle mie condizioni
diverse di vita,
ecco qui abbiamo provato
a rendere la casa
con la stessa libertà e reversibilità.
Questo è un altro esercizio,
un'altra riflessione.
Oggi chiaramente il mondo dei servizi
è sviluppatissimo.
I nuovi prodotti...
Anche noi designer incominciamo
a disegnare da un punto di vista estetico
nuovi prodotti e servizi.
Abbiamo provato ad immaginare
cosa vuol dire avere una casa
vicina a questo a queste strategie,
la possibilità ad esempio di non comprare
quasi niente, non possedere, ma accedere
alle cose, accedere alle funzioni,
per cui devo dormire, qualcuno mi metterà
a disposizione un letto.
Devo mangiare, alla stessa maniera...
Un po' come in ufficio
quando prendiamo un caffè caldo:
non è che ci preoccupiamo di comprare
la caffettiera, una cucina a gas,
o di riempire la caffettiera,
ci sono già delle macchinette,
che nemmeno compriamo, vengono fornite
da fornitori di servizi, e consumiamo
il nostro caffè caldo,
così come la Coca-Cola fresca,
senza preoccuparci di andare a comprare
ogni volta un frigorifero,
oppure una macchinetta del caffè.
Ecco, immaginare una casa
impostata in questo modo,
anche qui...
- Sì, vai avanti. Si vede.
- Si vede, questa casa... Terrificante.
- È un'immagine... Allucinante.
Dove lo stencil è sostituito da questi
numeri verdi per accedere a servizi,
e però ho una casa veramente liberata.
Liberata dall'arredo chiaramente,
dall'architettura, che impone uno stile
e una casa senza stile,
quindi lo stile sarà dato dai prodotti.
Liberata da una dimensione patrimoniale,
quindi non investo soldi
in tecnologie obsolescenti
così come faccio in ufficio,
diceva Dante.
Non compro il computer,
ma compro un contratto di servizio,
di assistenza,
che mi rifornisce di volta in volta
con tecnologie attuali, upgrade, eccetera.
Quindi tutte le mie risorse finanziarie
andranno non nel comprare
quello che mi serve, ma nel comprare
quello che mi piace,
e nell'immagine precedente si vedevano
vasi cinesi e quadri antichi.
Quindi piuttosto che comprare frigoriferi,
o lettini o cucce per cani
compro quello
che veramente mi piace.
Perché poi quando compro un frigorifero,
dopo cinque sei sette anni,
e questa è un'implicazione interessante
di questa casa servizio,
è che il frigorifero non è mio,
ma ritorna all'azienda che me l'ha fornito
per cui c'è tutta un'implicazione
sul ciclo di vita del prodotto,
che se invece è mio lo prendo e lo porto
in discarica, con tutte le problematiche
che ci sono nella separazione
dei materiali, eccetera.
Questo ad esempio è un frigorifero
interessante, una specie di quarantottore,
una specie di trolley, che noleggio al
supermercato per mettere i miei surgelati
la mia birra fresca, eccetera, lo porto
a casa, mi è fornito dal supermercato,
lo "pluggo" e diventa il mio frigorifero.
Magari per un single, se sono una famiglia
magari ho bisogno di cinque borse.
Questo ultimo esercizio teorico
e sperimentale è un intero condominio
costruito su questa logica
di spazi accessori,
una casa cosiddetta 'estesa',
a fronte quindi di spazi,
di standard molto piccoli in dotazione
a ciascun abitante, ci sono invece
degli spazi accessori
che scorrono lungo le facciate,
che possono essere
chiamati, prenotati, quindi 'on demand',
e che ampliano in qualche modo
la funzionalità della casa.
Posso chiamarmi in casa una pizzeria,
un luogo di culto, un giardino,
una gelateria, un Mc Donald's...
- Una stanza per vedere
la partita di calcio.
Sono tutte cose che vorremmo avere
nelle nostre piccole case,
però per avere tutto
ci vorrebbe un villone.
È fantastico: se io stasera
ho una una cenetta interessante,
e vorrei farla fuori, magari in estate,
chiamo e mi prenoto il giardinetto
o il chioschetto,
o se voglio fare un bagno
in una bella Jacuzzi...
- Tutti comportamenti che sono relegati
all'ambito del lusso,
che non ci possiamo permettere,
e che invece qui vengono realizzate
con un sistema meccanizzato, che è simile
a quello dello stoccaggio delle merci.
Accanto però si vedeva
anche un omino,
un contadino che tornava
dalla campagna sul ciucciarello,
che in effetti è la nuova dimensione
che vogliamo dare alle tecnologie:
da una parte ci sono le nuove tecnologie,
dall'altra c'è la possibilità di tornare indietro,
a un mondo premoderno,
dove non ci sono più spazi commerciali,
relegati nelle periferie
nei centri commerciali,
a spazi commerciali
che entrano in casa,
che già attualmente entrano in casa,
con i gruppi d'acquisto,
con il door-to-door.
È un mix tra nuove tecnologie
e nuovi concetti di benessere
che si riferiscono a un mondo premoderno.
- Grazie.
- Grazie mille.